es uno de los mayores paquetes de
sanciones contra rusia propuesto hasta
el momento el nuevo golpe de la unión
europea contra el gobierno de putin va
dirigido a su petróleo un reto también
para el bloque por su dependencia
energética
exterior seamos claros y easy
no será fácil porque algunos estados
miembros dependen en gran medida del
petróleo ruso pero simplemente debemos
hacerlo así que hoy proponemos prohibir
todo el petróleo ruso en europa con el
cambio la idea es ir reduciendo
progresivamente las importaciones y
compra de petróleo ruso en los próximos
seis meses hasta anular las por completo
para finales de año además de esta
prohibición el grupo de los 27 planea
sanciones contra altos cargos y
militares que participaron en la matanza
de lucha y el asedio a mariupol la
expulsión de más entidades bancarias del
sistema swift y la suspensión de la
emisión de cadenas de televisión
asociadas al gobierno ruso algo que no
convence a todos los miembros de la
unión europea ya que países como hungría
y bulgaria son fuertemente dependientes
del petróleo que envía moscú
hungría sólo podría aceptar esas
sanciones y el transporte de crudo por
oleoducto quedará exento en este caso se
mantendría el suministro energético de
hungría como esto no es así el paquete
no puede ser apoyado responsablemente
en esta línea la unión europea planea
aplicar excepciones para estos países
una vez aprobadas las sanciones no
obstante la propuesta debe obtener el
visto bueno de los 27 para poder entrar
en vigor